[Musique]
ce devait être une visite de routine
comme chaque mercredi à bourg-en-bresse
le corps médical visite les livres du
troisième âge
étiqueté patrimoine ses vétérans du
fonds anciens ont connu les guerres et
les révolutions mais sont encore robuste
ce jour là certains m'ont pourtant des
signes de fatigue
inquiétant au moindre contact ils
seraient 10 leur articulation grince et
leur peau semble flétrir il faut
déterminer la source du mal qui ronge
les livres établir un diagnostic
minutieusement on procède alors à
l'examen les lésions traumatiques et
contusions diverses nous dévoile une
histoire malheureusement commune
l'état des patients se dégrade du fait
de la présence de parasites sous la peau
la vermine attaque tout d'abord
l'épiderme
mais elle peut rapidement atteindre les
organes vitaux et causer des dommages
irréversibles
un traitement approfondi et à la
nécessaire éradication des indésirables
et reconstruction des tissus altéré
doivent être menées successivement mais
il arrive aussi que le mal soit plus
sévère
on dénombre plusieurs cas d'infection
généralisée conséquence de plaies mal
soignées dans lesquels s'engouffrent
l'humidité et le microbe de toutes
sortes on voit qu'elle a vraiment été
abîmée on repère l'année des traces de
croteau de cutter face à de telles
complications
la seule solution reste encore trop
souvent l'amputation des membres touchés
le malade est alors transporté dans une
ambulance climatisés pour subir une
intervention chirurgicale d'urgence
celle ci se déroule dans l'intimité du
bloc opératoire
rares sont les chirurgiens capable de
telles opérations et rares sont les
livres qui peuvent s'offrir leurs
services c'est quoi parler des fesses et
des éléments qu'on a dû enlever pour la
restauration qu'on ne pouvait pas
remettre sinon il allait créer une
nouvelle altération là c'était des
éléments ce qu'on appelle des clés donc
c'est des petits morceaux de parchemin
des parchemins de récupération d'envoi
il ya des vieilles calligraphie dessus
qui sont collés à ce niveau là au niveau
des nerfs et qui permettent de renforcer
les nerfs est normalement de stabiliser
la structure sauf que le parchemin avec
le temps souvent et frigide hi fi avec
parchemin plus cole est sacré plus des
détentions des difficultés à ouvrir
l'ouvragé qu'autre chose donc quand on
peut les enlever on les enlève donc là
on les a enlevées pour les remplacer
avec du papier japonais
à défaut d'un système performant
d'assurance maladie trop de livres
continuent de sombrer vers une lente
agonie pour ceux qui ont pu être opérés
cole d'amidon et papiers japonais
viennent ensuite masquer les entailles
les graisses permettent aujourd'hui aux
patients de retrouver une apparence
proche de celle qu'il avait avant la
maladie
il subsiste néanmoins des cicatrices qui
marque à jamais le corps du malade donc
là en fait tout ça là c'est du papier
qui a été cédée greffe on appelle ça des
greffes ou des comblements de lacunes
mais tout ça c'était du papier qui a été
remis pour pour combler tous les goûts
toutes les parties manquantes
on vient de tous a surclassé des lacunes
qui ont été causés très certainement par
des petits rongeurs et qui plus on va
vers le faire ne boucle fonds d'ouvragés
couple voix qui se sont qui se sont
amusés
débute alors pour ces miraculés une
phase de convalescence
ils sont gardés soigneusement à
l'observation dans un environnement
neutre qui doit leur permettre de se
reconstruire avec comme horizon leur
réinsertion à la bibliothèque
[Musique]